A question.
When did
Before that, a question
that I will begin with, that I'll pose
to you all.
What is the greatest threat
to humanity
from the creation of Adam
until the end of time, until Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
rolls up the heavens a scroll?
What did our prophet sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam tell us was the greatest
single greatest threat on humanity? Does
anyone know this narration that I have
in mind?
Huh?
Al Masih ad-Dajjal. Yes, very good.
The prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
tells us as much
in
a narration
reported by Imam Ahmad rahimahullah.
He said,
"Ma min sitna
after Allah knows
man he lucky Adam in a key and Sarah
man sit not in Messiah the job
Okay my color Salah Ali was selling. He
tells us
there will never be and there never was
a fitna a fitna meaning a threat
that is more severe
on all of humanity
than the threat
of a Messiah the job
no threat has ever been nor will ever be
from the creation of Adam until the day
of judgement.
There is no threat greater than the
threat of a Messiah the job.
Now, I have two
two
signs or two
things that will occur before the
emergence of a Messiah the job which
will indicate
that a Messiah the job
is eminent. His emergence is eminent in
my mind. Obviously, there are many
indicators
but I have two particularly in my mind.
Let's see if anyone knows them. What is
one of the
signs
that his threat his emergence is
eminent?
Mhm.
He's no longer spoken about in the
member. Very good. There is one.
And that's actually the first one that
was on my mind. Very good.
One of the things that the prophet Salah
Ali was selling tells us
is that
al-Masih ad-Dajjal, he will emerge
when he is no longer mentioned on the
mimbar. Now, notice what he said, on the
mimbar. He didn't just say taught about
or spoken about
or taught in the masajid. He said on the
mimbar. What usually takes place on the
mimbar is the khutbah.
The obligatory knowledge that every
Muslim is obligated to come and seek at
least once a week.
Every able-bodied
Muslim,
you know, with certain criteria,
must come
and listen to
knowledge on the mimbar.
And one of those obligatory things
is warning people of al-Masih ad-Dajjal.
As a matter of fact, in the narration of
Ibn Umar,
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said,
he said, "Ma min nabiyyin min
al-anbiya'i
[Arabic recitation]
ad-Dajjal."
He said, "No prophet who has ever come
before me
has failed to warn his people
of the threat
of al-Masih ad-Dajjal."
From the time of Nuh
until our Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam.
That is how great of a threat he is
because his threat
is not just his physical person, his
physical emergence.
Al-Masih ad-Dajjal
will only emerge
when the environment
when the
when the stage is set
perfectly for him to emerge.
This is when he will emerge and for this
reason all of the prophets warned their
people about ad-Dajjal.
Why?
Because his threat begins from that
time. The nature of his threat
is concealing
bad with a veneer of good. This is the
nature of his threat.
Something that is bad
taking on the appearance of something
that is good. Something that is foul
having a good name. This is the the
nature of the fitna of ad-Dajjal.
Right?
for instance,
when
things like
for instance, riba.
Riba.
One of the most
filthy things a person can take.
If not the most filthy thing.
As a matter of fact, there was a man
who came to al- Imam Malik to ask him
what is the most terrible thing a human
being can consume.
And Imam Malik said, "Give me a few
days."
And he read the Quran during those days.
He reviewed the whole Quran.
And then he said,
"The most filthy thing the human being
can consume is riba."
This riba, this filth that really is
taking advantage
of the fortunate, taking advantage of
the less fortunate. That's the nature of
riba.
What is the name that we give it today
in our modern society?
What's it called?
No, not usury. Nobody uses that. What,
are we living in the 1700s?
Usury,
interest.
Huh?
What a nice name. This is my interest.
I Can Can you lend me $10? Sure, but
what interest do I have in those $10?
What do I get out of it? That's my
interest.
Right?
A terrible, filthy thing, but it has a
nice name.
And then a lot of times we translate it
into
our language
and we fail to use the
wordage of the prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. So, what do we call it
in Arabic, modern Arabic?
Fawa'id and fa'idah.
Right? If you want to know if something
is imported,
right?
Look at the name it gets.
The name is imported with with the thing
itself.
So, this is one example. There are many,
many, many examples of this.
Right?
They give them very nice names for very
terrible things. This is the nature of
al-Masih ad-Dajjal and his fitna.
Because when he comes,
he will embody all treachery in
humanity.
All of the treachery and audacity that
humanity has to muster up will be in
this one man.
A'udhu billah.
And so he'll emerge to the people
saying, "Hey, I I'm just a regular guy.
I just I I love Allah, too.
And, you know, we want to obey Allah."
He'll come out in this form. And then,
after a while, he'll start to say,
"Well, actually, he's a prophet now."
And then, after a while, he won't be
satisfied by that, so he'll say,
"Actually,
he is al-Masih ibn Maryam.
He's Isa. He's the return of Isa."
And then, after that, he will say that
he is God. He is Allah incarnate
[Arabic recitation]
And people will follow him, not
necessarily because they believe he's
God. Why will they follow him?
What will be the
incentive for people to follow al-Masih
ad-Dajjal?
Miracles.
Well, not miracles, but more like
Yeah,
sum that up in one word.
Mhm.
The incentive will be
worldly gain. That's the incentive. You
know, that sums up all those things.
The the the mountains of bread, the
mountains of meat, the the it's
incentives. The incentive The Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam said in
Sahih al-Imam Muslim that he will come
upon a land
and all of the gold and silver and
precious metals
in that land will
be extracted by Dajjal
and will follow him swarms of bees,
he said.
[Arabic recitation]
a'lam. That's what the Prophet
but that's the visual that he gives us.
And that's the incentive.
People want to get ahead.
Remember the Dajjal will emerge in a
time when
the
Furat River
will uncover a mountain of gold near Al
Iraq.
And everyone will start fighting over
this mountain of gold.
The prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said, "Out of every 100 99 people will
die
trying to
obtain or get some of this gold.
Each person
gambling his life
thinking that he will be the one
that this gold is meant for. That's the
exact wording of the narration.
You know, in you know, the younger
kids they say today main character
syndrome.
You know about it cuz you're a
youngster. Look at you with your very
jet black beard, masha Allah. I know
Osama knows this too, right? Main
character syndrome.
You know this. You're cool, right? Do
you know these these terms?
main character syndrome. Everybody
thinks he's the he's the main character
of the the story. He's the hero of the
story. Everyone thinks that they're the
Disney princess or that they're the
Disney prince and this world is all
there to really serve him and his
interests and all the great things and
the glory was meant for him, right? This
is correct. This is the kind of thought
that people will have. It's no longer
sufficient to just be a regular person.
I'm just a regular person. No.
We call each other king and queen,
right?
Do your thing, king, you know?
Keep going, queen. Slay, queen, right?
Why do you need to be a king and a
queen? I need my husband to be a king. I
need him to be the leader of the pack. I
need him to be the alpha. What's wrong
with just being a regular person?
Nobody wants to be that anymore.
Everybody wants to be the main
character. Everybody wants to be the
hero or the heroine that everyone else
reveres and revolves around. This is a
disease. It's a sickness. Right? Because
if everybody wants to be the leader,
who's going to be led?
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala designed human
beings
that out of every 100, or say 99%
of humanity are followers.
And 1% are leaders. He designed us that
way on purpose.
There's a reason behind that, a wisdom.
And the prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam taught us to take pride in
following the truth.
In following our leaders.
[Silence]
In a sahih, he said, "Whoever obeys my
leaders that I have selected, then he
has obeyed me. And whoever obeys me has
in turn obeyed Allah.
And whoever disobeys my leaders has
disobeyed me.
And whoever disobeys me has disobeyed
Allah. Right? So, he taught us to take
pride in our adherence, our following of
our good leaders, our righteous leaders.
But now we want every everyone wants to
be the leader. Everyone wants to be the
main guy. Everyone wants to be the And
this is really can be boiled down to
vanity, a desire for vanity, for
reverence, right? Not leadership, you
desire it so that you can help people.
It's the desire of the perks of
leadership, right?
And so
a Dajjal will emerge during this time.
How can you get people to kill each
other and put their lives at risk for
wealth, for gold, a mountain of gold? 99
out of 100 will perish for the sake of
this gold, each one thinking he is the
one that it was meant for. This is the
kind of
stage set that a Dajjal will emerge
on.
Now, there's one other
indicator of a Dajjal that I have in
mind.
one other sign that a Dajjal's
emergence is eminent. Who can
tell us what that is?
Huh?
there will be wars, yes, and I
know what you're talking about. There
will be a a major war between the
Muslimin and the their enemies, but
I'm speaking about something that is
more environmental, something that kind
of permeates all of humanity, a kind of
attitude or a an an illness, if you
will, an ailment that will be
commonplace in the world that will mark
the emergence of a Dajjal. I think you
got it. What is it?
Mm.
No, still, that's not That's one, and
that's one. It's just not the one I have
in mind.
Huh?
A slave giving birth to her master. This
is another sign of the emergence of a
dajjal, but it's not the one I have in
mind.
Oh Sheikh, just tell us. Why are you
making us guess? Because I want I want
you all to benefit as I'm benefiting.
Right?
Think of all the
instances.
Immorality in general. People will be
immoral and godless. That's for sure.
But a specific ailment.
A man came and asked
the prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam
when the hour will be. That's the hint.
The narration is in Sahih al-Bukhari.
A man came. He was in the masjid. He had
just this.
And he was talking.
He was speaking and teaching the
companions.
And someone came in and said, "Ya Rasul
Allah, mata sa'a?"
"Oh messenger of Allah, when is the
hour?"
And so the prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam heard his question.
And then he continued speaking as if he
didn't hear him.
So some of the companions thought
he didn't hear him.
And other companions hypothesized that
no, he did hear him, but he didn't like
the question.
So he ignored it.
And then after he concluded
he said, "Ayna sa'il?" "Where is the
person that asked when the hour is?"
So he said, "Ana ya Rasul Allah."
And then he said, "If this happens, then
this." What did he say?
No, that's a different one.
Hadha ba'du hadith.
Dig deep into those brains.
Dig deep into those minds. You got so
much info in your minds.
You know, a lot of people they say
things like, "You know, I don't have a
good memory." or
human being's mind is incredible.
Right? The human being's mind is so
dense, so deep, so incredible
that
some of the scholars say that the word
alamien
is human beings.
Rabbul alamien.
And that the human being is called a
alam
because each human being contains in his
mind and heart the equivalent of the
entirety of the universe.
What is it? He said,
Huh?
Raf'ul ilm is one, but that's not the
narration. That knowledge will become
scarce.
I'll I'll give you another one, huh?
Iwa, thank you. We got it. I had to pull
it out of him cuz I knew he was going to
get it. He He's very good at these
at these riddles. Al huzariyat. And
the shafa for
Akeed lam makan as weird a shafa
for huzariyat. So,
he says sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
Itha dhuyi'atil amanah
fantasir al sa'.
He said, "If the entrustment is lost,
then await the hour."
So, then the man asked another question.
He said,
He said, "Oh messenger of Allah, and how
does the entrustment get lost?
What is meant by that exactly?"
He said,
a man.
"If the entrustment is lost,
then await the hour."
The man responded, "And how will the
entrustment be lost? How will general
untrustworthiness become
permeating of our environment?" He
said,
"If you see positions
filled by those who are unrightful to
those positions,
then the entrustment has been lost.
And if you see that happening,
await the emergence of a Dajjal that
morning or that night."
any day, any minute.
Now, let me ask you a question. Does it
seem our time maybe embodies that?
Huh?
Tell me one politician who is in the
position of leadership that is rightful
to that position.
Name one.
Donald Trump. There you go.
From the east or the west.
Someone who is and not just the highest
levels of power.
Even the levels of power of such as
teaching.
A teacher, someone who is teaching
let's say in a public school. How many
of those teachers have the character
to teach, the true desire
for their students to learn? Professors,
are those the smartest people who have
filled those positions, or are those the
most politic people that have filled
those positions? They knew which palms
to grease, they knew which elbows to
rub, and they got and they assumed those
positions.
Right?
And this has been going on for years and
years. If you have one ignorant person
take a position of power,
deep down that person knows he's
unrightful to that position. So,
immediately he will seek to fill all
other people or all other positions
around him with his
you know, his his
trustees and his confidants in
order to secure himself.
And so, you have people that are
fighting not for
the execution of their work or amana,
but you have people fighting simply for
the
purpose of remaining in a position of
power.
To the point that now we have even
sayings about it. We say, you know,
"Absolute power corrupts absolutely."
Right? That's not necessarily true, but
it is for our time. Yes.
we look at the time of the companions
of the Allah and them, they had a lot of
power. The Khalifa of the Muslimin had
incredible power.
Yet, it did not corrupt them. Abu Bakr
and Omar and Uthman and Ali and
Hussein and even in the time of
[Arabic recitation]
but corruption did make its way in
there.
Right? Over time.
And so, when you see that it becomes the
norm, one-off is just a one-off. A
coincidence is just a coincidence.
But, when it becomes the norm,
that
you go and you find a person in any
position,
and they are actually equipped and fit
for that position, and you're surprised.
Deep down, you think, "Wow, that's rare
to find a judge that's fair,
or to find a lawyer that's truthful,
right? Or to find a doctor that is
genuinely caring about his patients."
Alhamdulillah, for the Muslimin, we have
that seed of good planted in our hearts,
[Arabic recitation]
always bear fruit. Correct?
But, imagine the world without that seed
of good. How many truly good doctors
do you meet? They have
a great entrustment.
And
have many of them not been trained to to
churn the money machine? Yes, very much.
And it is rare to find a doctor that
does not do that. Right? Or to find a
judge that is fair, or a lawyer that is
truthful, or
a spouse that, you know, and so,
this is the greater sign of the
emergence of El Messiah Dajjal.
This is something for us to think about,
and we'll end with this, because a lot
of times,
when we hear about El Messiah Dajjal,
all of us know about El Messiah Dajjal.
Every one of us.
But, how many of us truly envision that
El Messiah Dajjal could emerge in our
time?
If you feel deep down, "No, it's not
going to be in my lifetime. This is
something This is for other people way,
way, way in the future. That's exactly
exactly the psychology
that had the Dajjal is counting on
people to have when he emerges.
So, that people will not be able to
recognize him.
And the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said that when he emerges, run,
flee, because a man will think himself
truly a believer until he is faced with
a Dajjal.
Right? And most people will fail that
test. Most.
Now,
so let's let's say Allah forgive them in
fitnat Masih ad-Dajjal.
Mhm.
[Silence]
The purpose of a Dajjal?
Aha.
Sahih.
So, why a Dajjal? What's the wisdom
behind a Dajjal?
I tell you what.
Good. I tell you what.
That
is a very good question.
As a matter of fact, it's not just a
good question. It's one of the best
questions
that all of us should be thinking about.
However, the answer to that question
is a khutbah. So, I'm not going to give
that khutbah right now, okay? But, we we
can talk about this tomorrow. Tomorrow
night, inshallah, we can visit that. All
right? I I can do it, but
I don't think everybody's going to be
very happy with you and I if we
you know, drone on for another 20
minutes. But, we'll talk about that
tomorrow. Let Let us continue this
[Arabic recitation]
I want to say hi. Hi, man. How are you?
Good to see you.
Okay.
Good to see you. See you, too. I haven't
seen the boys very much. Easy at school.
I mean,
they come every now and then, but